bonjour à tous en général quand on me
demande ce que je fais dans la vie que
j'explique que je suis chercheur en
physique on me dit très souvent ou là la
physique c'est la matière à laquelle
vous ne comprenez rien et que je
détestais et bien aujourd'hui mon
objectif c'est de changer ses a priori
en vous montrant que vous allez réussir
à comprendre un mécanisme de physique
très complexe à savoir l'accélération
d'électrons relativiste et ceci juste
avec une image simple avant toute chose
qu'est ce qu'un électron toute la
matière qui nous entoure est composée
d'atomes
par exemple si je m'intéresse à l'eau
qui est dans ceux vers celle ci est
faite de la molécule h2o qui est
constitué de deux atomes d'hydrogène et
d'un atome d'oxygène et chacun de ces
atomes sont eux mêmes formés d'un noyau
entouré d'un nuage d'électrons et c'est
à ces électrons de nous allons nous
intéresser aujourd'hui mais pas
n'importe lesquels les électrons qui
sont les plus rapides
ceux qui veulent atteindre la vitesse de
la lumière qui est de 300 mille
kilomètres par seconde
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur ça
correspond à faire huit fois le tour de
la terre en une simple secondes
la première question qu'on se pose c'est
pourquoi des électrons delthil atteindre
une vitesse aussi élevé et bien c'est
pour nous aider nous les êtres humains
en effet ils vont par exemple pouvoir
nous aider en médecine si une personne a
une tumeur cancéreuse à un endroit qui
n'est pas opérable par chirurgie eh bien
on va pouvoir utiliser des faisceaux
d'électrons rapide afin de l'y radiés et
la détruire c'est le principe de la
radiothérapie
ensuite ils vont pouvoir aussi nous
aider en biologie en chimie ou en
physique afin de mesurer des structures
de molécule de protéines complexes pour
mieux les comprendre et en les
comprenant mieux on va par exemple
pouvoir comprendre pourquoi une cellule
va se transformer en cellules
cancéreuses
maintenant que l'on sait pourquoi la
question c'est comment en tant que
physicien je vais pouvoir aider ces
électrons à mon tour aller aussi vite
quel moyen de transport vais-je pouvoir
leur fournir en tant qu'humain nous
avons différents moyens de transport
pour aller vite à notre disposition par
exemple la moto la voiture de course
voir l'avion de chasse et bien le moyen
de transport de prédilection d'un
électron c'est le surf avant de
comprendre comment un électron à pouvoir
surfer comprenons comme un surfeur surf
kitty accélération sur un corps d'un
corps dit qu'il faut exercer une force
sur celui ci
quelles forces s'exercent sur vous et
moi à tout moment et en ce moment même
c'est la gravité la force d'attraction
de la terre évidemment le sol exerce une
force de rappel qu'il a compensé c'est
ce qui fait qu'on n'est pas en train de
tomber vers le centre de la terre
maintenant intéressons-nous un surfer
sur une vague sur ce surfeur la gravité
s'appliquent également
sauf que ce que l'on voit c'est que la
force de rappel de la vague ne sera plus
verticale ne va plus la compenser et
donc va y avoir une résultante des
forces qui va avoir tendance à faire
tomber le surfeur vers le creux de la
vague et c'est grâce à cette force qui
va pouvoir surfer maintenant quelle
force peut-on exercer sur un électro
pour le comprendre il faut revenir l'une
des propriétés fondamentales d'un
électron qui est qu'il possède une
charge électrique
donc il va être sensible aux champs
électriques
en d'autres termes si je le place entre
deux électrodes auquel j'applique une
tension
ça génère un champ électrique qui exerce
une force sur l'électron est cette force
va pouvoir l'accélérer c'est sur ce
principe que sont basés la plupart des
accélérateurs actuelle que vous
retrouvez dans vos hôpitaux ou dans la
plupart des laboratoires de recherche et
c'est ce qu'on appelle des accélérateurs
linéaires une image simple pour le
comprendre
c'est comme si l'électron est en train
de skier sur une grande pente de champ
électrique et pour qu'un skieur prennent
beaucoup de vitesse il va lui falloir
une très grande pente
ainsi ces accélérateurs vont être de
grande taille suivant les applications
que l'on veut en faire de quelques
mètres à quelques kilomètres et donc ils
vont coûter très cher de quelques
millions à quelques milliards de dollars
l'un des objectifs actuels les
physiciens
ça va être de trouver un nouveau
mécanisme d'accélération plus efficace
afin de réduire la taille et donc les
coûts de ces accélérateurs et c'est ce
que va nous permettre le surf d'électre
donc maintenant que l'on sait que l'on
veut utiliser un champ électrique pour
l'accélérer et qu'on voulait faire
surfer cherchons un champ électrique en
forme de vague et un champ électrique en
forme de vague vous en connaissez tous
un puisque c'est la lumière
en effet la lumière est une onde
électromagnétique safdie ça veut dire
qu'elle possède un champ électrique qui
oscille dans le temps et la trajectoire
d'un électron dans cette onde de lumière
va être équivalente à la trajectoire
d'un surfeur dans une note de vagues
pour comprendre comment un électron
vasseur fait la lumière comprenant
d'abord comment à surfer sur une vague
pour qu'un surfeur prennent une vague il
y à trois conditions nécessaires
tout d'abord si on considère une vague
très petit par rapport à la taille
caractéristiques du surfeur celle ci
n'aura pas assez de puissance pour
l'emporter
on va donc avoir besoin d'une vague qui
a une taille minimale pour emporter
notre serveur
ensuite il va falloir que le surfeur est
une vitesse initiale
on a tous en tête l'image d'un surfeur
qui rament pour prendre une vague et
bien il le fait pour avoir une vitesse
initiale suffisante pour partir dans
cette vague et enfin la dernière
condition qu'on appelle la condition de
l'instant initial c'est à quel moment le
surfeur rame sur la vague si ils rament
une fois la vague passé on se doute
qu'il ne pourra pas la prendre et si un
surfeur ne respecte pas une seule de ces
trois conditions
c'est ce que l'on va appeler ici le
syndrome de labourer nous allons avoir
deux catégories de trajectoire sur une
vague
d'un côté les surfers de l'autre les
bouées les surfers vont respecter les
bonnes conditions initiales ils vont
donc pouvoir rester sur le front de la
vague et avoir un grand déplacement sur
celle ci au contraire les bouées ne vont
pas respecter les conditions initiales
ainsi à un moment la bouée va se
retrouver sur le front de vagues et
avoir tendance à être poussé vers
l'avant mais elle ne va pas y rester
elle va aussi les avec la vague à un
moment se retrouver à l'arrière et avoir
tendance à être repoussés vers l'arrière
ainsi son déplacement total une fois que
la vague sera passée sera nul
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle de la physique
théorique du surf et on va passer à ce
que vous attendez tous du surf
expérimental grâce à cette vidéo où l'on
va retrouver nos deux catégories de
surfer en haut à gauche
nous aurons nos cobayes surfeurs qui
vont ramer pour cette expérience est en
bas à droite nos cobayes boury est ce
que l'on voit c'est que les surfeurs qui
rament vont se mettre dans les bonnes
conditions pour partir sur la vague
rester sur son front et avoir un grand
déplacement sur celle ci ce que ne dit
pas encore la physique c'est si
l'électron prend autant de plaisir à
surfer la lumière qu'un surfeur surfer
une vague
maintenant la conclusion de cette vidéo
c'est quoi c'est que notre expérience
valident nos hypothèses théoriques et si
vous avez compris la physique du surf
avec ces trois conditions
eh bien vous avez déjà compris la
physique du third électrons puisque ça
va respecter exactement ces trois mêmes
conditions en effet il va falloir que la
vague lumineuse soit suffisamment
intense pour emporter l'électron ensuite
il va falloir que l'électron une vitesse
initiale suffisante pour prendre cette
vague et enfin il va falloir qu'ils
partent aux bons mots maintenant mon
travail de physiciens savent est de
trouver le meilleur spot de surf à
électrons possible qu'ils respectent ces
trois conditions
alors pour ceux ci on va le faire
ensemble la première condition c'est que
la bac soit suffisamment intense pour
emporter l'électron pour cela on va
utiliser des faisceaux laser de très
haute puissance en effet aujourd'hui on
arrive à créer des impulsions lasers
dont le champ électrique à cette forme
dire c'est une impulsion très courte
elle dure dix millionième de
milliardième de seconde en termes de
surf pour que ce soit plus simple c'est
une impulsion qui dure deux vagues
sauf que ces vagues sont extrêmement
puissante puisque chacune à la puissance
équivalente à 25 milles réacteurs
nucléaires et ce faisceau laser de haute
puissance
on va le focaliser sur un point qui fait
la taille d'un dixième de l'épaisseur
d'un cheveu donc sur un dixième de
l'épaisseur d'un cheveu
on a 25 mille réacteurs nucléaires est
ce si ça va suffire à remplir notre
première condition
maintenant notre deuxième condition
c'est que les électrons doivent avoir
une vitesse initiale suffisante pour
partir sur la vague
revenons à notre faisceau laser qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on
va vouloir insérer des électrons à
l'endroit où le laser est le plus
intense et que ces électrons et déjà une
vitesse initiale suffisante
l'une des premières idées qu'ont eue les
physiciens pour réaliser ceci ça a été
d'utiliser un accélérateur déjà
existants pour
prêt à accélérer les électrons lors
d'une première étape et ensuite de les
insérer à l'endroit au laser est intense
pour les accélérer lors d'une seconde
étape par surf mais intéressons-nous
plus particulièrement à l'interaction
entre l'électron et le laser
voici comment le paquet d'électrons
était inséré dans l' impulsion laser ce
que l'on voit c'est que certains
électrons se trouve bien au niveau des
vagues et ceux ci vont pouvoir surfer ça
valide donc notre deuxième condition de
la vitesse initiale des électrons
seulement un grand nombre d'électrons ne
se situe pas au niveau des vagues
ceux ci vont donc agir comme des bouées
et complètement noyée notre signal
d'électrons surfer et donc notre
troisième condition de l'instant initial
d'insertion des électrons n'est pas
validé il se trouve que pendant mon
doctorat les étudiants tout autre
système qui est la réflexion d'un laser
de haute puissance sur un miroir
évidemment ce qui se passe c'est que le
miroir va réfléchir
le faisceau laser mais à de si haute
intensité lumineuse
il y à un second effet des électrons
vont être arrachés du miroir est éjecté
dans le sens dans la direction du laser
réfléchi ils ne le sont pas n'importe
comment ils le sont à des instants très
précis qui correspondent exactement à
nos vagues de lumière ainsi ces
électrons pouvoir surfer et ça va
valider notre troisième condition
maintenant il nous reste à le prouver
pour le prouver nous allons placer un
détecteur sur ce détecteur on va d'abord
mesure évidemment le profil du faisceau
laser est ce que je vais vous montrer
c'est que le profil du faisceau
d'électrons va nous dire s'ils ont surfé
ou s'ils ont agi comme des bouées pour
ceux ci intéressons-nous encore une fois
l'interaction entre les électrons et le
laser un point très important que vous
voyez en bas à droite sur votre image en
c'est que le faisceau laser est plus
intense en son centre que sur ses côtés
et en fait c'est la même chose pour une
vague qui concentre son énergie en son
centre par rapport à ces bornes
maintenant si je place une bouée sur
cette vague et que je fais la somme des
forces la force de rappel de la vague ne
va pas compenser la gravité exactement
va y avoir une résultante des forces qui
va avoir tendance à repousser la boue
est loin de l'endroit où la vague est
intense il va se passer exactement la
même chose pour nos électrons bout et
ils vont aussi les deux hôtes en bas
avec nos vagues lumineuse mais ils vont
avoir tendance à être repoussée du
centre où le faisceau laser est le plus
intense
ainsi sur mon détecteur ce que je vais
observer c'est que tous les électrons
d'en sortir tout autour du faisceau
laser et former un anneau maintenant
intéressons nous aux surfeurs ceci
également on partir sur le côté la vague
mais c'est pour garder leur vitesse est
un point important c'est qu'ils vont
rester sur le front de la vague
les électrons surfer vont faire de même
ils vont voir uniquement le front de la
vague lumineuse
ça veut dire qu'ils vont voir qu'un seul
sens du champ électrique et donc n'être
accéléré que suivant cette direction ils
vont donc tous sortir du même côté du
faisceau laser ainsi ce que l'on va
observer sur notre détecteur c'est un
paquet d'électrons uniquement d'un côté
du faisceau laser
en conclusion on a deux catégories de
trajectoire les bouées et les surfers
qui n'ont pas du tout la même signature
sont à détecteur et même si tous les
électrons n'ont pas agi soit comme des
bouées sont comme les surfeurs et bien
sûr notre secteur on va avoir une image
comme celle ci où on va observer ces
deux signatures et on saura donc qu'elle
électrons sur fait qu'elle électron ont
agi comme des boules et ceci c'est une
image théorique
pendant mon doctorat nous avons
réaliser cette expérience et voici ce
que l'on a mesuré on voit un accord
frappant entre le ferais faisceau
d'électrons mesure est expérimentalement
et celui théorique et donc ceci ça veut
dire comme tout à l'heure lors de notre
vidéo de surf que notre expérience
valide notre théorie et ce résultat
en fait c'est la première fois qu'on a
pu prouver que les électrons peuvent bel
et bien surfer sur la lumière et en quoi
est ce un résultat important c'est à
dire ce que vous vous demandez tout
c'est pourquoi les électrons surfeurs
sont ils plus cool que les autres et
bien parce que maintenant nous avons
deux catégories d'accélérateur les
accélérateurs linéaires parce qu'il
électrons sur une grande pente de champ
électrique et les accélérateurs par surf
sur la lumière l'une des différences
majeures entre les deux c'est que le
champ électrique atteignable est un
million de fois plus élevé pour le surf
ça veut dire que si je veux une certaine
vitesse d'électrons et qu'avant j'avais
besoin d'une distance d'accélération 200
m aujourd'hui je n'ai plus besoin que
d'une distance d'accélération de 0.1 mm
pour la même performance
donc on est passé d'un accélérateur qui
faisait la taille d'un stade de rugby un
accélérateur qui fait l'épaisseur d'un
poil de ma moustache
en d'autres termes en ayant multiplié le
champ électrique par un million on a pu
diviser la distance d'accélération par
un million pour obtenir la même
performance
donc on va potentiellement pouvoir
réduire considérablement la taille des
accélérateurs donc leurs coûts et les
rendre beaucoup plus accessible pour
toutes les applications que l'on veut en
faire en conclusion j'aimerais vous dire
que depuis 15 minutes
vous avez compris des concepts de
physique des ondes de mécanique
newtonienne de physique des lasers
d'électromagnétisme de physique des
plasmas de relativité restreinte et
d'interaction en particules sans même
vous en apercevoir
et en plus ce soir vous pourrez dire à
vos amis autour d'une bonne bière que
vous avez tout compris à l'accélération
d'électrons relativiste par champ laser
ultra intense injecté par miroir plasma
oscillant et ceci grâce au surf
adrien leblanc
[Applaudissements]